- أهلاً بكم مجدداً في سلسلة فهم
المعلومات والحوسبة الكمية.
اسمي John Watrous وأنا المدير التقني
لقسم التعليم في IBM Quantum.
هذا هو الدرس الثالث من السلسلة. في الدرسين الأولين، تحدثنا عن أساسيات
المعلومات الكمية.
أولاً للأنظمة المفردة المعزولة ثم للأنظمة المتعددة.
ناقشنا أيضاً قياسات الأساس القياسي
والعمليات الأحادية في كل من إعدادات
النظام المفرد والمتعدد.
في هذا الدرس، سنقدم
نموذج الـ circuit الكمي، الذي يعطينا طريقة معيارية لوصف الحوسبات الكمية،
ويمكننا أيضاً استخدام الـ circuits الكمية لوصف البروتوكولات الكمية وأنواع أخرى من التفاعلات التي تشمل أجهزة كمية متعددة.
بالإضافة إلى الـ circuits الكمية، سنناقش أيضاً بعض
المفاهيم الرياضية المهمة المرتبطة بالمعلومات الكمية،
وسنستخدمها لملاحظة
بعض القيود الأساسية على المعلومات الكمية وما يمكننا فعله بالـ circuits الكمية.
هذا سيهيئنا جيداً للدرس
الذي يلي هذا حيث سنرى بعض
الأمثلة المهمة جداً وذلك سيختتم
الوحدة الأولى من السلسلة
حول أساسيات المعلومات الكمية.
إليكم نظرة عامة على الدرس. سنبدأ بنموذج الـ circuit الكمي وسنرى كيف يعمل.
ثم سنتحدث عن مفهوم
الجداء الداخلي المهم جداً، وكذلك التعامد والإسقاطات،
المرتبطة بالجداء الداخلي. لم نناقش هذه الأمور
في الدرسين الأولين، لأننا حقاً لم نكن
بحاجة لذلك، لكن الآن نحتاج.
الجداء الداخلي يوفر لنا
أداة رياضية لا يمكننا ببساطة الاستغناء عنها.
لن نتمكن من التقدم كثيراً في فهم المعلومات الكمية
والحوسبة بدون الجداء الداخلي.
وفي الجزء الثالث من الدرس، سنلقي نظرة على
بعض القيود المهمة للمعلومات الكمية.
في النهاية، ما نريد فعله هو استكشاف أشياء مثيرة
يمكننا فعلها بالمعلومات الكمية، لكن لكي نفعل ذلك بفعالية،
نحتاج أن نكون على دراية ببعض
الأشياء التي لا يمكننا فعلها.
بشكل خاص، سنناقش
مفهوم الطور الشامل ولماذا الأطوار الشاملة غير ذات صلة.
سنرى صياغة
نظرية عدم الاستنساخ، التي تخبرنا أن الحالات الكمية لا يمكن نسخها بشكل عام، وسنرى أن حالتين كميتين
لا يمكن التمييز بينهما
بشكل مثالي ما لم تكونا متعامدتين، وهذا قيد أساسي
يجب أن نكون على علم به.
الموضوع الأول للدرس
هو نموذج الـ circuit الكمي، وهو نموذج حوسبة
يوفر لنا طريقة
لوصف الحوسبات الكمية.
نموذج الـ circuit الكمي مبني
على مفهوم أعم في علوم الحاسوب وهو الـ circuit، ويمكنك تعريف العديد
من نماذج الحوسبة المختلفة
بناءً على هذا المفهوم العام.
الفكرة الأساسية هي أن
الـ circuit يتكون من أسلاك تحمل المعلومات، وgates تمثل العمليات
التي تُطبق على
المعلومات التي تحملها الأسلاك.
مصطلح circuit هو في الواقع
اسم غريب نوعاً ما لهذا النوع من النماذج
لأن كلمة circuit
عادة تشير إلى
مسار دائري من نوع ما.
لكن عندما نتحدث عن الـ circuits
كنماذج حوسبة، فإننا عادة نتحدث
عن circuits غير دورية
حيث لا يُسمح بالمسارات الدائرية.
لنكون أكثر دقة، لأغراض
هذه السلسلة، سنشترط أن
المعلومات تتدفق دائماً من اليسار إلى اليمين في أي circuit.
فإذا فضلت، يمكنك
التفكير في الـ circuits على أنها تصف تسلسلات من العمليات حيث يسير الزمن من اليسار إلى اليمين.
إليكم مثالاً على circuit بولياني حيث تحمل الأسلاك قيماً
ثنائية، إما صفر أو واحد،
والـ gates تمثل
عمليات المنطق البولياني.
الأسلاك تُمثل بخطوط، وهنا لدينا بتّان
للإدخال مُسمّيان X و Y،
وإذا أردنا معرفة
ما يفعله الـ circuit لاختيار معين من المدخلات، فإننا ننشر القيم على
الأسلاك من اليسار إلى اليمين،
حسب التأثيرات
التي تملكها الـ gates على القيم
المحمولة بواسطة الأسلاك.
فمثلاً، يمكننا
النظر فيما يحدث عندما نبدأ بسلك الإدخال العلوي مضبوطاً على القيمة واحد وسلك الإدخال السفلي
مضبوطاً على القيمة صفر.
هذان سلكا الإدخال يؤديان
إلى هاتين النقطتين هنا، واللتان تمثلان عمليات التفرع، مما يعني أن القيمة تُنسخ
بحيث يمكن حملها
للأمام عبر أسلاك متعددة.
فإذا فعلنا ذلك، فإن هذين
السلكين يأخذان القيمة واحد، وهي نفس هذه، وهذان السلكان يأخذان القيمة صفر،
وهي نفس هذه.
هنا لدينا gate NOT والتي
تُشار إليها برمز النفي المنطقي، فالقيمة
الخارجة هي صفر،
وهي النفي المنطقي للواحد. وبالمثل، القيمة
الخارجة من هذه الـ gate هي واحد وهي
النفي المنطقي للصفر.
هاتان الـ gates هما gates AND،
وهذه الـ gate هي gate OR، وإذا تابعنا
ونشرنا القيم
عبر الـ circuit، بتقييم
الـ gates بشكل مناسب، نرى أن القيمة النهائية
على هذا السلك هنا هي واحد.
إذاً الـ circuit بالكامل يصف
تسلسلاً من العمليات المركبة كما يوضح الشكل، وينتج لنا دالة
من بتّين إلى بت واحد
في هذه الحالة بالذات. لكن بشكل عام، يمكن أن يكون هناك أي عدد
من بتات الإدخال والإخراج.
هذا الـ circuit بالتحديد يحسب العملية الحصرية OR للبتّين المدخلين، فالإخراج يكون واحداً
إذا وفقط إذا كان بالضبط
أحد البتّين المدخلين مضبوطاً على واحد والآخر مضبوط على صفر، لكن هذا ليس
مهماً حقاً، إنه مجرد مثال.
إنها حقيقة أساسية عن الـ circuits البوليانية أن أي دالة من أي عدد من البتات إلى أي عدد من البتات يمكن حسابها
بواسطة circuit بولياني ما، رغم أنك أحياناً قد
تحتاج إلى circuit كبير جداً لحساب الدالة
التي تهتم بها.
هناك أنماط أخرى تُستخدم
لوصف الـ circuits.
مثلاً، هذا الشكل
يمثل نفس الـ circuit تماماً كما كان لدينا سابقاً، باستخدام نمط ربما أكثر شيوعاً
في الهندسة الكهربائية، حيث توجد اصطلاحات للأشكال التي تمثل gates مختلفة.
لن نستخدم هذا
النمط بالذات، لكننا سنقدم
بعض الرموز الخاصة بنا لـ gates كمية مختلفة، مثل gates Hadamard،
وgates NOT المتحكم بها،
وgates Toffoli، وغيرها.
كملاحظة جانبية، هنا يمكننا رؤية أصل
مصطلح circuit.
في سياق الهندسة الكهربائية، من الطبيعي جداً
التفكير في الكهرباء وهي تدور عبر circuit.
لكن في هذه السلسلة لا
نتحدث عن الكهرباء تتحرك عبر circuits، بل نتحدث عن المعلومات
تتحرك عبر circuits.
ومرة أخرى بالنسبة لنا، ستكون دائماً غير دورية، حيث المعلومات
تتحرك من اليسار إلى اليمين.
إليكم مثالاً مختلفاً على
نوع مختلف من الـ circuits يُسمى circuit حسابي.
هذه المرة تخزن الأسلاك أرقاماً والـ gates تمثل
عمليات حسابية مثل الجمع والضرب.
هنا يمكنكم رؤية مثال
على circuit حسابي.
ليس مهماً لأغراض
هذا الدرس ماذا يفعل، إنه مجرد مثال
يهدف لإيصال فكرة أن هناك مفاهيم مختلفة
للـ circuits.
يمكننا أيضاً التفكير في
circuits تتضمن العشوائية، مثلاً، حيث الـ gates تمثل
عمليات احتمالية، وإذا أردت،
يمكنك الجلوس طوال اليوم وابتكار نماذج حوسبة جديدة مبنية على مفهوم الـ circuits.
في نموذج الـ circuit الكمي،
الأسلاك تمثل qubit، والـ gates تمثل كلاً من العمليات الأحادية والقياسات.
إليكم مثالاً بسيطاً جداً
على circuit كمي.
هناك qubit واحد فقط في هذا الـ circuit، ويُمثل
بالخط الأفقي، والـ gates، المشار إليها
بالمربعات،
تمثل عمليات أحادية تُجرى على هذا الـ qubit.
فلا توجد قياسات
في هذا المثال بالذات.
إذا أردنا إعطاء
الـ qubit اسماً مثل X، يمكننا الإشارة لذلك في الرسم بوضع X هنا
تماماً، هذا اختياري.
تماماً كما كان لدينا في الـ circuit البولياني منذ لحظات، يمكننا التفكير في هذا الـ circuit
على أنه يمثل تسلسلاً من العمليات حيث يسير الزمن
من اليسار إلى اليمين.
فنبدأ بـ X،
ونطبق أول gate، وهي gate Hadamard
يليها gate S،
ثم gate Hadamard
أخرى، وأخيراً gate T.
رأينا هذه العمليات
قرب نهاية الدرس الأول، وهنا يمكنكم رؤية
أوصافها المصفوفية.
فعندما نجري هذه
العمليات الأربع بالترتيب، أي أولاً H، ثم
S، ثم H مرة أخرى، ثم T،
العملية المجمعة تُعطى
بهذا الجداء هنا، مع الأخذ بعين الاعتبار أن الترتيب
ينعكس بشكل أساسي
كما تحدثنا في الدرس الأول. إذا أجرينا ضرب المصفوفات، نحصل على هذه المصفوفة هنا،
وبالتالي تأثير الـ circuit
على الـ qubit X يوصف بهذه المصفوفة الأحادية.
أحياناً نريد أن نشير صراحة في رسم الـ circuit الكمي
إلى المدخل الذي نغذيه، ويمكننا فعل ذلك كما ترون هنا.
في هذه الحالة، نُدخل
Ket 0 في الـ circuit.
هذا شائع جداً. غالباً ما نأخذ Ket 0 كحالة
مهيأة للـ qubit، لكن هذا ليس ضرورياً.
يمكننا أيضاً التفكير في
تطبيق الـ circuit على حالة مختلفة.
إذا اخترنا، يمكننا أيضاً
الإشارة إلى حالة الإخراج التي نحصل عليها هكذا.
إليكم مثالاً آخر حيث
هذه المرة لدينا qubit اثنان مسميان X و Y كما
ترون في الرسم.
هنا لدينا gate Hadamard، تُطبق على الـ qubit Y، تليها الـ gate المشار إليها بهذا
الرمز هنا،
وهي gate NOT المتحكم بها. تحدثنا عن عملية
NOT المتحكم بها في الدرس السابق،
وهنا في هذا الرسم يمكننا
أن نرى أن qubit التحكم هو Y، المشار إليه
بالدائرة الصغيرة المملوءة،
وqubit الهدف هو X، المشار إليه بالدائرة الكبيرة التي تبدو وكأن فيها علامة زائد.
يبدو نوعاً ما كرمز
العملية الحصرية OR فهذا منطقي.
يمكنك أن تتخيل أن أي حالة
كلاسيكية مخزنة في Y يتم تطبيق XOR عليها على الـ qubit X.
ومن باب الوضوح، إليكم الرسم الذي
يوضح تأثير هذه الـ gate على حالات الأساس القياسي،
حيث نفترض أن A
و B قيم ثنائية.
للحالات الأخرى، يتحدد التأثير
بالخطية كالمعتاد.
الآن، قبل أن نتقدم أكثر، سيكون من المفيد
التصريح بشكل واضح باصطلاح سنتبعه بخصوص كيفية ترتيب الـ qubits
في رسومات الـ circuit الكمي مثل هذا.
والاصطلاح هو أن
الترتيب من الأسفل إلى الأعلى في رسم الـ circuit الكمي يعادل الترتيب من اليسار إلى اليمين
كما في الثنائية أو الجداء التنسوري.
هذا اصطلاح سنتبعه
في السلسلة وهو أيضاً الاصطلاح
المستخدم في Qiskit.
فبالنسبة لهذا الـ circuit بالتحديد هنا، نفكر فيه على أنه
يعمل على زوج من الـ qubits وهما X و Y،
X يأتي أولاً لأنه في الأسفل، و Y يأتي أخيراً أو ثانياً في هذه الحالة، لأنه في الأعلى.
الطريقة التي يمكنك التفكير بها
بصرياً، في حال ساعدت، هي تخيل تدوير
هذا الـ circuit باتجاه عقارب الساعة بحيث تكون المدخلات في الأعلى
والمخرجات في الأسفل، وسيكون ترتيب
الـ qubits صحيحاً.
أحياناً هذا الترتيب يُربك الناس، فتأكدوا من الحفاظ على
هذا الاصطلاح في أذهانكم.
فعندما نفكر في التأثير الذي يصفه هذا الـ circuit، ما لدينا أولاً هو
gate Hadamard مطبقة على Y
ثم gate NOT المتحكم بها
على الـ qubit الاثنين حيث Y هو المتحكم
و X هو الهدف.
إذا أردنا كتابة مصفوفة أحادية تصف التأثير
المجمع لهاتين الـ gates، يمكننا فعل ذلك.
أولاً، نعتبر gate Hadamard على Y.
نطبق gate Hadamard على Y ولا نفعل شيئاً لـ X، وهو ما يعادل
إجراء عملية الهوية على X.
وبالتالي تأثير gate Hadamard على كلا الـ qubit معاً
يُعطى بالجداء التنسوري لمصفوفة الهوية و
المصفوفة التي تمثل
عملية Hadamard على Y.
يبدو هكذا، مع الأخذ بعين الاعتبار
اصطلاحنا أن X يأتي أولاً و Y يأتي ثانياً، فهو
الهوية مضروبة تنسورياً في H.
ثم نطبق عملية
NOT المتحكم بها، التي لها هذا التمثيل
المصفوفي، ومرة أخرى، هذا يتوافق مع اصطلاحنا.
الـ qubit الثاني Y هو المتحكم والـ qubit الأول X هو الهدف.
لا تتردد في إيقاف الفيديو والتحقق من أن هذا منطقي وسأتوقف عن تذكيرك بذلك.
يمكنك إيقاف هذه الفيديوهات، والرجوع ومشاهدة أجزاء
بقدر ما تريد، وضبط سرعة التشغيل إذا أردت، واستخدامها بأي
طريقة تناسبك.
على أي حال، عندما نركب
العمليتين معاً، التأثير المجمع يوصف
بهذا الجداء هنا،
وهاتان المصفوفتان
تُضربان بهذا الترتيب لأن Hadamard يُجرى أولاً وNOT المتحكم بها
يُجرى ثانياً،
ومرة أخرى، هذا يتوافق
مع ما تحدثنا عنه في الدرس الأول حيث الترتيب
ينعكس بشكل أساسي.
إذا أجرينا ضرب المصفوفات، نحصل على هذه المصفوفة هنا.
ويمكننا الآن استنتاج من هذه المصفوفة ما يفعله الـ circuit بحالات
الأساس القياسي.
إذا شغلنا الـ circuit على المدخل 0, 0، أي Ket 0 للـ qubit الأول، Ket 0 للـ qubit الثاني،
النتيجة هي حالة Bell فاي+، والتي يمكننا رؤيتها من
العمود الأول للمصفوفة.
إذا أدخلنا 0, 1، نحصل على حالة فاي-، وواحد صفر يعطينا حالة ساي+،
و 1, 1 يعطينا ليس ساي-، بل -1 ضرب ساي-.
علامة السالب ليست
مهمة حقاً هنا. إذا لم تكن تريدها هنا، يمكنك إجراء عملية
تبديل على الـ qubit الاثنين
للتخلص منها ولن تُفسد
ما حدث لحالات الأساس القياسي الثلاث الأولى.
لكن هذا ليس مهماً حقاً
لأغراض هذا المثال.
باختصار، الـ circuit له هذا التأثير هنا على حالات الأساس القياسي.
عندما تفكر في
ما يفعله circuit معين، لا تحتاج إلى المرور بتحويل
المصفوفات وضربها معاً،
يمكنك أيضاً تتبع التأثير
الذي يملكه الـ circuit على حالات معينة، وفي كثير من الحالات هذا سيكون
الخيار المفضل.
في هذا المثال، على سبيل المثال، يمكننا رؤية ما يفعله الـ circuit
بحالة 0, 0 من خلال فحص تأثير الـ gates.
الحالة الابتدائية، التي
سميناها باي صفر هنا، فقط لتجنب اسم
قد يكون مربكاً مع حالات Bell هي 0, 0.
نطبق gate Hadamard والحالة التي نحصل عليها هي 0+ والتي يمكننا توسيعها هكذا،
ثم عملية NOT المتحكم بها تأخذ هذه الحالة إلى حالة فاي+، والتي يمكننا رؤيتها بالتفكير
في التأثير الذي تملكه NOT المتحكم بها على
حالات الأساس القياسي،
ويمكنك فعل نفس
الشيء لحالات الأساس القياسي الثلاث الأخرى أو أي
حالة أخرى.
يمكننا أيضاً دمج البتات الكلاسيكية في رسومات الـ circuit الكمي.
تُشار إليها بخطوط
مزدوجة كما ترون في هذا الرسم.
أي أن A و B بتّات كلاسيكية و X و Y هما qubits.
لدينا نفس الـ gates الأحادية كما في المثال السابق، وهذه الرموز هنا تمثل قياسات الأساس القياسي
تحديداً بعد إجراء العمليتين
الأحاديتين، يُجرى قياس الأساس القياسي
على Y
والنتيجة تُكتب فوق
البت الكلاسيكي B، وبالمثل يُقاس X والنتيجة تُكتب في البت A.
هنا يمكنكم رؤية أن الـ qubits X و Y تستمر بعد قياسها.
لكن من الشائع جداً
ألا نهتم كثيراً بالـ qubits
بعد قياسها.
أحياناً كل ما يهمنا
هو نتيجة القياس. وفي حالة كهذه، يمكننا استخدام الاختصار
الذي ترونه هنا
حيث تدخل qubits للقياسات وتخرج بتات كلاسيكية.
المفهوم هنا هو أنه
بمجرد قياس الـ qubits، يتم تجاهلها أو إهمالها ويتم حمل النتيجة
الكلاسيكية للقياس للأمام.
الآن مع استمرار السلسلة، سنرى العديد
من أمثلة الـ circuits الكمية وستكون عادة
أكثر تعقيداً بكثير من الأمثلة
البسيطة جداً التي رأيناها للتو.
كما ذكرت سابقاً، تُستخدم رموز مختلفة
لـ gates مختلفة.
gates الـ qubit المفرد عادة
تُكتب كمربعات بحرف يشير
إلى العملية المراد إجراؤها.
أحياناً هذه الـ gates
المختلفة تكون مرمزة بالألوان لتعني أشياء مختلفة، لكن
سنتجاهل ذلك الآن.
رأينا بالفعل
gate NOT المتحكم بها.
gates التبديل تُرمز
كما ترون هنا، وgates Toffoli وgates Fredkin
تُرمز كما ترون هنا.
تذكروا أن gate Toffoli هي gate NOT متحكم بها مزدوجة التحكم وgate Fredkin هي
gate تبديل متحكم بها.
فهذه الرموز متوافقة
مع فكرة أن qubit التحكم يُشار إليه
بدائرة ممتلئة بخط يربطه
بالـ gate التي يتحكم بها.
بشكل عام، qubits التحكم
لا يجب أن تكون في الأعلى وهذه الـ gates لا يجب
أن تعمل على qubits متجاورة، مما يعني أن هذه الـ gates
يمكن أن تمتد عبر
qubits أخرى لا تعمل عليها، وسنرى ذلك
يحدث في دروس مستقبلية.
شيء آخر نفعله كثيراً عند استخدام نموذج الـ circuit الكمي هو اعتبار العمليات الأحادية الاعتباطية
على أي عدد من الـ qubits
وكأنها gates مفردة كما ترون هنا.
فقط برسم مستطيل مع تسمية تتوافق
مع أي عملية أحادية.
في هذه الحالة إنها
عملية أحادية U ما.
بالطبع، لا نعرف
ما هي U من هذا الرسم، يجب أن نفترض أن
U معرفة بطريقة ما أو أننا نعتبر عملية أحادية اعتباطية
U ما، ربما. يمكن أن تكون مثلاً أننا
فقط نريد التفكير في U كإجراء فرعي
من باب الوضوح.
نستخدم أيضاً هذا الترميز
الذي ترونه هنا لعملية U المتحكم بها
حيث يُشار إلى qubit التحكم بدائرة ممتلئة
تماماً كما كان لدينا سابقاً.
هذه كانت مقدمة مختصرة
لنموذج الـ circuit الكمي. وكما قلت سابقاً، سنرى المزيد من
أمثلة الـ circuits الكمية
مع استمرارنا في السلسلة.
في الجزء التالي من الدرس، سنلقي
نظرة على الجداء الداخلي، والتعامد والإسقاطات، وهي مفاهيم مهمة جداً
في المعلومات والحوسبة الكمية.
سنبدأ بالجداء الداخلي.
تذكروا أنه عندما
نستخدم ترميز Dirac، فإن Ket هو متجه عمودي
و Bra هو متجه أفقي،
وتحديداً متجه
Bra المقابل لمتجه عمودي معين هو المرافق المنقول
لذلك المتجه العمودي.
فبالنسبة لهذا المتجه هنا، نحصل على متجه Bra المقابل بنقل المتجه
وكأنه مصفوفة،
مما يعني وضعه على جنبه ثم أخذ المرافق المركب لكل مدخل من المدخلات.
الآن، افترض أن لدينا Ket اثنين بنفس عدد المدخلات مثل هذا.
إذا شكلنا هذا القوس هنا، والذي يعني ببساطة
أن نأخذ جداء Bra و Ket،
وكأنهما مصفوفتان،
نحصل على هذا التعبير
الذي ترونه هنا، وهو كمية قياسية، أو بعبارة
أخرى عدد مركب.
هذه القيمة تُسمى الجداء
الداخلي لهذين المتجهين.
يمكنكم أيضاً التفكير في الجداء الداخلي بدلالة متجهات
على الشكل الذي ترونه هنا حيث المتجهات معبر عنها
كتركيبات خطية
لمتجهات الأساس القياسي.
الجداء الداخلي لهذين المتجهين يُعرف بنفس الطريقة
كما سابقاً، Bra ساي ضرب Ket فاي والذي يمكننا التعبير عنه
كجداء هكذا.
وإذا حسبنا وبسطنا، نبقى مع هذا التعبير هنا للجداء الداخلي، وهو مشابه لما كان لدينا سابقاً،
إلا أننا هذه المرة
نأخذ المجموع على عناصر مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية، وهي سيغما في هذه الحالة.
إليكم مثالاً يهدف لإعطائكم صورة هندسية لكيفية
عمل الجداء الداخلي.
هنا رسمت دائرة
في فضاء ثنائي الأبعاد يتوافق مع qubit، وطالما نقصر انتباهنا
على متجهات ذات مدخلات أعداد حقيقية، يمكننا رسمها كنقاط على هذا المستوى.
لنأخذ فاي ليكون
هذا المتجه هنا.
إنه متجه وحدة، يمكننا رؤية ذلك من خلال
حساب النظيم الإقليدي وهذا ما تمثله هذه الدائرة،
إنها جميع متجهات الوحدة
ذات المدخلات من الأعداد الحقيقية.
لنأخذ أيضاً ساي ليكون
هذا المتجه هنا، والذي هو أيضاً متجه وحدة.
إنه حالة السالب في الواقع، لكن هنا نسميه فقط ساي.
إذا حسبنا الجداء
الداخلي لهذين المتجهين، نحصل على واحد ناقص الجذر التربيعي لثلاثة على اثنين ضرب جذر اثنين،
والذي يساوي تقريباً -1/4.
قيمة هذا الجداء الداخلي تساوي جيب تمام الزاوية
بين المتجهين، والذي يمكنكم رؤيته هنا في الشكل.
هذا شيء صحيح
بشكل عام لمتجهات الوحدة. إذا كان لدينا متجها وحدة وكلاهما له مدخلات أعداد حقيقية،
فإن الجداء الداخلي بينهما يساوي جيب تمام
الزاوية بينهما.
بشكل خاص، إذا كان الجداء
الداخلي يساوي صفراً، كما في هذا المثال، حيث غيرنا ساي ليكون
هذه الحالة هنا،
فإن المتجهين يجب أن
يكونا بزاوية 90 درجة أحدهما مع الآخر.
كل هذا يُعمم على
متجهات في أي بُعد، بالمناسبة، طالما أن
المدخلات أعداد حقيقية، وليس فقط لمتجهات ثنائية الأبعاد.
إذا كانت المدخلات أعداداً مركبة، فالصورة لا تعمل
حقاً بعد الآن، لكن مع ذلك، الجداء الداخلي مفيد
بنفس القدر كما سنرى.
الجداء الداخلي له بعض
الخصائص المهمة جداً وسنأخذ بعض اللحظات لملاحظة بعض تلك الخصائص الآن.
أولاً هناك علاقة
بين الجداء الداخلي والنظيم الإقليدي.
إذا أخذنا الجداء الداخلي
لأي متجه مع نفسه، نحصل على مربع النظيم الإقليدي.
فيمكننا بدلاً من ذلك القول أن النظيم الإقليدي لمتجه يساوي الجذر
التربيعي للجداء الداخلي
لذلك المتجه مع نفسه. هذه ليست صدفة، هذه
علاقة أساسية، وهنا يمكننا أن نرى أنه لو لم يكن لدينا
المرافقات المركبة في تعريف الجداء الداخلي، فإن هذه الصيغة
لن تكون صحيحة بعد الآن، ولن يكون لدينا مفهوم مفيد
بهذه العلاقة الأساسية
مع النظيم الإقليدي.
ثانياً، الجداء الداخلي
متماثل مرافقياً، مما يعني أنه إذا بدلنا
ترتيب المتغيرين، فإن القيمة التي نحصل عليها
للجداء الداخلي تأخذ مرافقها.
هذا معبر عنه
بهذه المعادلة هنا ومن السهل جداً رؤية لماذا يحدث هذا لهذين التعبيرين
للجداء الداخلي للمتجهين بالترتيبين الممكنين.
الجداء الداخلي خطي
في المتغير الثاني. تحديداً، إذا عرفنا متجهاً فاي على أنه هذه التركيبة
الخطية لمتجهين،
فاي واحد وفاي اثنين، فإن الجداء الداخلي لأي
متجه ساي مع فاي هو نفس التركيبة الخطية
من الجداءين الداخليين،
وهذا يتبع مباشرة
من حقيقة أن ضرب المصفوفات خطي.
ولدينا أيضاً أن الجداء
الداخلي خطي مرافقياً في المتغير الأول، والذي يمكنكم رؤيته معبراً عنه هنا.
إذا كان ساي هذه التركيبة
الخطية من المتجهات، فإذا أخذنا الجداء
الداخلي لساي وفاي،
فإن Bra ساي يصبح هذا المتجه الذي نراه هنا حيث نأخذ المرافق
المركب لبيتا واحد وبيتا اثنين،
وهذه هي النتيجة وهذا ما نعنيه
بالخطية المرافقية.
والخاصية الأخيرة للجداء الداخلي التي أريد ذكرها هي
متراجحة كوشي-شفارتس المفيدة للغاية.
لأي متجهين، ساي وفاي، القيمة المطلقة للجداء الداخلي لا يمكن أبداً أن تكون أكبر من
جداء النظيمين الإقليديين
للمتجهين. وعلاوة على ذلك، الطريقة الوحيدة لتساوي
طرفي المتراجحة هي إذا كان المتجهان
مرتبطين خطياً،
مما يعني أن أحدهما يساوي كمية قياسية ما مضروبة في الآخر.
هذه في الواقع واحدة من
أكثر المتراجحات استخداماً في كل الرياضيات و
نستخدمها مراراً وتكراراً عندما نتحدث عن
المعلومات الكمية،
فمن الجيد جداً معرفتها.
بعد ذلك، سنتحدث عن
مفهومي التعامد والتعامد المعياري المرتبطين
بالجداء الداخلي
وتحديداً، بالجداء
الداخلي للمتجهات الذي يساوي صفراً.
لنكون دقيقين، إذا كان لدينا
متجهان، ساي وفاي، نقول أنهما متعامدان
إذا كان جداؤهما الداخلي
يساوي صفراً. والطريقة التي يمكننا التفكير
بها في المتجهات المتعامدة حدسياً هي أنها
بزوايا قائمة مع بعضها،
أو بدلاً من ذلك، أنها
عمودية على بعضها البعض.
أحياناً يستخدم الناس مصطلح متعامد للإشارة إلى أشياء لا علاقة لها
ببعضها، مثل القول أن قضية ما
متعامدة مع أخرى،
لكن هذا واضح أنه غير رسمي وليس ذا معنى حقيقي
بالمعنى الرياضي، لكن العلاقة واضحة إذا فكرت في المتجهات المتعامدة
على أنها تشير
ليس في اتجاهات متعاكسة، بل في اتجاهات مختلفة تماماً مثل الشمال مقابل الغرب على سبيل المثال.
إذا كانت لدينا مجموعة من المتجهات، نقول أن المجموعة متعامدة إذا كان أي متجهين مختلفين
يُختاران من تلك المجموعة
متعامدين بالضرورة مع بعضهما، وهو ما يمكننا التعبير عنه
كما ترون هنا،
المجموعة المتعامدة معيارياً هي
ببساطة مجموعة متعامدة من متجهات الوحدة.
المتجهات في المجموعات المتعامدة
لا يجب بالضرورة أن تكون متجهات وحدة، وفي الواقع يمكن أن يكون
المتجه الصفري
عنصراً في مجموعة متعامدة، لكن في المجموعة المتعامدة معيارياً، كل متجه يجب أن يكون متجه وحدة
بالإضافة إلى
شرط أن المجموعة متعامدة.
بالنظر إلى ما نعرفه عن العلاقة بين الجداء الداخلي
والنظيم الإقليدي، يمكننا التعبير عن هذا
الشرط بإيجاز
كما ترون هنا.
وأخيراً، الأساس المتعامد معيارياً هو ببساطة مجموعة متعامدة
معيارياً تشكل أساساً لأي فضاء متجهي
نتحدث عنه.
مثلاً، إذا أخذنا أي
مجموعة حالات كلاسيكية سيغما وفكرنا في مجموعة
جميع متجهات الأساس القياسي،
نرى أن هذه مجموعة متعامدة معيارياً وفي الواقع هي أساس متعامد معياري للفضاء من جميع المتجهات التي تتوافق مدخلاتها مع
مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية سيغما.
هذه كلها متجهات وحدة
ومتعامدة في أزواج، فهي مجموعة متعامدة معيارياً.
ولأنها أساس أيضاً، فلدينا أنها أساس متعامد معياري.
المجموعات المتعامدة معيارياً
مستقلة خطياً دائماً بالمناسبة، فكلما كانت
لديك مجموعة متعامدة معيارياً، ستكون دائماً أساساً متعامداً
معيارياً لفضاء جزئي ما،
لكن في هذه الحالة، لدينا أساس للفضاء بأكمله الذي نعمل فيه.
مثال آخر هو المجموعة
التي تحتوي على Ket+ و Ket-.
هذان المتجهان متعامدان، جداؤهما الداخلي يساوي صفراً.
وكلاهما متجها وحدة ويمتدان في
الفضاء ثنائي الأبعاد للمتجهات المتوافقة مع qubit واحد، فيشكلان أساساً متعامداً
معيارياً لذلك الفضاء.
مثال آخر هو أساس Bell، وهو أساس متعامد معياري لفضاء جميع
المتجهات رباعية الأبعاد المتوافقة مع qubit اثنين.
المجموعة التي تحتوي على Ket 0
و Ket+ من ناحية أخرى، ليست مجموعة متعامدة لأن الجداء الداخلي بين
هذين المتجهين غير صفري.
كلاهما متجها وحدة وهذا أساس لفضاء المتجهات المتوافق مع qubit، لكن ليس لدينا تعامد.
إليكم حقيقة مفيدة عن المجموعات المتعامدة معيارياً سنستخدمها من وقت لآخر.
افترضوا أن لدينا مجموعة
متعامدة معيارياً من المتجهات، تحديداً، لنفترض
أن لدينا M متجهاً في هذه المجموعة، ساي واحد حتى ساي M،
حيث نفترض أن هذه المتجهات مأخوذة من فضاء متجهي
بُعده N، أو بعبارة أخرى، كل
متجه له M مدخلاً.
كما ذكرت بالفعل، المجموعات المتعامدة معيارياً
مستقلة خطياً دائماً، فلا يمكن أن يكون M أكبر من N،
لكن يمكن أن يكون M أصغر من N، وهذه هي الحالة التي
نهتم بها.
وما تنص عليه الحقيقة هو
أنه إذا كان M أصغر من N، فمن الممكن دائماً
إضافة متجهات إضافية
إلى المجموعة التي بدأنا بها للحصول على
أساس متعامد معياري لفضائنا.
بالتحديد، يجب بالضرورة أن
توجد متجهات ساي M+1 حتى ساي N بحيث تشكل المجموعة الكاملة
أساساً متعامداً معيارياً.
فلا يمكنك أبداً أن تضع
نفسك في مأزق، إن صح التعبير، باختيار مجموعة
متعامدة معيارياً من المتجهات لا يمكن توسيعها
لتشكل أساساً متعامداً معيارياً.
أحياناً يمكنك فقط النظر
إلى المجموعة التي بدأت بها ومعرفة كيف توسعها لتشكل أساساً متعامداً معيارياً، لكن بديل يعمل دائماً
هو استخدام إجراء يُعرف بعملية التعامد المعياري
لـ Gram-Schmidt لبناء هذه المتجهات.
لن أشرح هذا
الإجراء في هذا الدرس أو في هذه السلسلة لأن التفاصيل ليست
مهمة حقاً لنا، لكن بالطبع يمكنكم البحث
عنه إذا كنتم فضوليين.
إنه شيء يمكن أن
يُنفذه حاسوب في حال كان ذلك مهماً، فلا
يوجد إبداع مطلوب، إنه مجرد إجراء آلي.
أحد أسباب كون هذه
حقيقة مفيدة جداً يتعلق بعلاقة وثيقة قائمة بين الأساسات المتعامدة
معيارياً والمصفوفات الأحادية.
بالتحديد، لأي مصفوفة مربعة U، الشروط الثلاثة التي ترونها هنا متكافئة دائماً،
مما يعني أنها إما
كلها صحيحة أو كلها خاطئة.
الشرط الأول يقول
أن U مصفوفة أحادية، مما يعني أن كلاً من U المرافقة المنقولة ضرب U و U ضرب U المرافقة المنقولة
يساويان مصفوفة الهوية.
الشرط الثاني
يقول أن صفوف U تشكل أساساً متعامداً معيارياً
والشرط الثالث يقول أن أعمدة U
تشكل أساساً متعامداً معيارياً.
ليس من الصعب حقاً
رؤية لماذا هذا التكافؤ صحيح.
لتبسيط الأمور، لنلقِ نظرة على
مصفوفة 3×3 U كما ترون هنا، حيث يمكن أن تكون المدخلات أي
أعداد مركبة تريدونها.
هنا على الجانب الأيسر كتبت U المرافقة المنقولة
فقط للتسهيل.
إذا شكلنا ثلاثة متجهات
من أعمدة U، والتي سميت هنا ساي
واحد، ساي اثنين وساي ثلاثة، فإذا أخذنا
جداء U المرافقة المنقولة و U،
يمكنكم التحقق من أن كل
مدخل في الجداء يُعطى بجداء داخلي لمتجهات كما نرى هنا في هذا النمط.
والآن عندما تفكرون في شرط أن U أحادية، وهو مكافئ لأن تكون هذه المصفوفة مساوية لمصفوفة الهوية،
ترون أنه مكافئ
لأن تشكل المتجهات الثلاثة مجموعة متعامدة معيارياً.
المدخلات القطرية يجب
أن تساوي كلها واحداً، فهذه بالضرورة متجهات وحدة، والمدخلات
غير القطرية يجب أن تساوي صفراً،
فهي مجموعة متعامدة من المتجهات.
فأن تكون U أحادية مكافئ لأن تشكل الأعمدة مجموعة متعامدة معيارياً،
وهذا يجب أن يكون أساساً لأن عدد المتجهات في المجموعة، وهو ثلاثة في هذه الحالة، يتطابق مع بُعد الفضاء
الذي نعمل فيه. يمكنك اتباع حجة مماثلة للصفوف بدلاً من الأعمدة لتستنتج أن كون U
أحادية مكافئ
لأن تشكل الصفوف أساساً متعامداً معيارياً.
لا يعمل الأمر بنفس السلاسة لأننا يجب أن نجري تعديلاً لجعل المرافقات المركبة
تعمل بالشكل الصحيح، لكن الفكرة هي نفسها.
طريقة بديلة للقيام بذلك، وهي مباشرة جداً، هي إثبات أن المصفوفة أحادية إذا وفقط إذا كان منقولها أحادياً.
وهنا أعني فعلاً المنقول وليس المرافق المنقول.
من البديهي جداً من
تعريف المصفوفات الأحادية، أن المرافق المنقول
لأي مصفوفة أحادية هو أحادي،
لكن أيضاً منقول أي مصفوفة أحادية هو أحادي.
في أي حال، لدينا
التكافؤ بين هذه الشروط الثلاثة على أي مصفوفة مربعة U، ويمكننا دمج هذا التكافؤ
مع الحقيقة حول
توسيع المجموعات المتعامدة معيارياً لتشكل أساسات متعامدة معيارياً لابتكار مصفوفات أحادية
تفعل أشياء مثيرة
أو تلبي احتياجات متنوعة قد نواجهها.
تحديداً كلما كانت
لدينا مجموعة متعامدة معيارياً من M متجهاً، ستوجد دائماً مصفوفة أحادية U
أعمدتها الـ M الأولى هي المتجهات من تلك المجموعة المتعامدة معيارياً.
الأعمدة المتبقية
يمكن دائماً ملؤها بحيث نحصل على مصفوفة أحادية باختيارها بحيث تشكل الأعمدة
أساساً متعامداً معيارياً. هذه ستكون حقيقة مفيدة
جداً لدينا في متناول اليد.
وموضوع أخير لهذا
القسم من الدرس هو مفهوم الإسقاط.
المصفوفة المربعة باي يُقال
أنها إسقاط أو مصفوفة إسقاط إذا كانت الخاصيتان
المذكورتان هنا صحيحتين معاً.
هذه باي كبيرة بالمناسبة، إنها اختيار نموذجي جداً لحرف يُستخدم للدلالة على الإسقاط.
غالباً ما نعطي هذه الأنواع النموذجية من الأسماء للكائنات مثل المصفوفات فقط لتسهيل التعرف عليها وتنظيم الأمور،
لكن يمكنك استخدام أي اسم تريده. على أي حال، الشرط الأول هو أن باي تساوي المرافق المنقول لنفسها.
بشكل عام، عندما تكون لدينا مصفوفة تساوي المرافق المنقول
لنفسها، نقول أنها مصفوفة هرميتية.
فالشرط الأول يمكن صياغته بديلاً على أن باي هرميتية.
الشرط الثاني هو
أنه إذا ربعنا باي، أي ضربنا باي
في نفسها، نحصل على باي مرة أخرى.
فتربيع باي لا يفعل شيئاً لها.
فكرة الإسقاط
حدسياً هي أنها مشابهة
لإسقاط صورة على شاشة أو إنزال
عمود على خط مستقيم
مثلاً. عندما تضرب
متجهاً بإسقاط، ما تفعله هو بمعنى ما
ترك جزء منه كما هو
وتصفير الباقي.
فإذا طبقت
إسقاطاً مرة ثانية، لا يفعل شيئاً لأنك
بالفعل صفّرت الجزء الذي يصفره الإسقاط.
مثال على الإسقاط
هو هذه المصفوفة هنا لأي اختيار لمتجه وحدة ساي.
يمكننا التحقق من أنها تستوفي
الشروط المطلوبة واحداً تلو الآخر.
للشرط الأول، نحسب
المرافق المنقول وهذا هو المرافق
المنقول لجداء.
فيمكننا استخدام هذه الصيغة هنا للمرافق المنقول
لجداء لمساعدتنا.
ما تحصل عليه هو جداء
المرافقات المنقولة، لكن الترتيب ينعكس.
يحدث ذلك بسبب
جزء النقل.
فإذا طبقنا تلك الصيغة، نحصل على هذه المساواة هنا ويمكننا بعدها التبسيط للحصول
على المصفوفة الأصلية.
لاحظوا بالمناسبة، أننا لم نستخدم حقيقة
أن ساي متجه وحدة.
في الواقع، هذه المصفوفة
هرميتية لأي متجه ساي، وليس فقط لمتجهات الوحدة.
وللشرط الثاني، نربع باي ونحصل على
هذا التعبير هنا وهو يساوي المصفوفة
الأصلية هذه المرة
لأن ساي متجه وحدة، فهذا الجداء الداخلي
هنا يساوي واحداً وهذا هو المكان الذي يأتي فيه
افتراض أن ساي متجه وحدة
في الاعتبار.
يمكننا تعميم هذا المثال والبدء بمجموعة متعامدة معيارياً.
وإذا شكلنا هذه المصفوفة هنا، حيث نجمع الإسقاطات المتوافقة مع المتجهات الفردية، نحصل على إسقاط.
هنا على الشاشة، يمكنكم رؤية حسابات تكشف ذلك وسأترك لكم
فحصها إذا أردتم.
وبالمثل مع المثال
الأول، الشرط الثاني هو حيث يُستخدم التعامد المعياري
للمجموعة.
ما يفعله هذا الإسقاط إذا
ضربته في متجه، هو إسقاط ذلك
المتجه على الفضاء الجزئي الممتد بواسطة هذه المجموعة من المتجهات،
وهو بطريقة مجردة
مثل إنزال عمود على ذلك الفضاء الجزئي، وبمجرد أن تكون
في ذلك الفضاء الجزئي، لا يفعل الإسقاط شيئاً.
فمصفوفات كهذه هي
أمثلة على الإسقاطات، والآن في الواقع استنفدنا
كل الاحتمالات.
كل مصفوفة إسقاط تأخذ هذا الشكل لاختيار ما لمجموعة متعامدة معيارياً.
المصفوفة الصفرية هي إسقاط، فيجب أن نتأكد من
تضمينها إذا أردنا الحصول على كل إسقاط.
فلنكون واضحين بشأن هذا، نحن نسمح
بإمكانية أن M يساوي صفراً وهذا يعطينا مجموعاً فارغاً،
والذي يمكننا تفسيره كالمصفوفة الصفرية.
الآن بعد أن أصبح لدينا
مفهوم الإسقاط في متناولنا، يمكننا تعريف فئة أعم
من القياسات الكمية تُعرف بالقياسات الإسقاطية.
هذا ليس المفهوم الأعم
للقياس، لكنه أعم بكثير من قياسات الأساس القياسي
وسيكون مفيداً جداً
دمجه في وصفنا
للمعلومات الكمية.
القياس الإسقاطي يُعرف بأي مجموعة من الإسقاطات
تستوفي الشرط الذي ترونه هنا، وهو أن الإسقاطات
يكون مجموعها مصفوفة الهوية.
هنا M يمكن أن يكون
أي عدد صحيح موجب تريده طالما أن هذه كلها إسقاطات وهذا الشرط صحيح،
المجموعة تعرف
قياساً إسقاطياً.
القياس الموصوف
بمجموعة كهذه يعمل كالتالي عندما
تقيس أي حالة كمية ساي.
أولاً تحصل على نتيجة
بين واحد و M، حيث M هو عدد الإسقاطات.
لكل نتيجة ممكنة K، احتمال الحصول على تلك النتيجة هو مربع النظيم الإقليدي
للمتجه الذي تحصل عليه
بضرب ساي في باي
K، الإسقاط رقم K.
يمكننا أيضاً كتابة هذه
الكمية كما ترون هنا.
هذه المساواة تأتي من العلاقة بين النظيم
الإقليدي والجداء الداخلي مع حقيقة
أن باي K إسقاط.
من الشكل الثاني، مع الشرط الذي لدينا على هذه الإسقاطات، يمكننا أن نرى فوراً، بالخطية، أن احتمالاتنا
ستجمع دائماً إلى واحد،
مع الأخذ بعين الاعتبار أن ساي
يجب أن يكون متجه وحدة.
وثانياً، بافتراض أننا
حصلنا على النتيجة K، فإن حالة النظام
تنهار إلى الحالة الكمية التي نحصل عليها بتطبيع أي
متجه حصلنا عليه من الإسقاط.
سنلقي نظرة على بعض
الأمثلة بعد لحظات، لكن قبل ذلك، دعوني أذكر أننا لا نحتاج فعلاً
إلى ترقيم النتائج
الممكنة من واحد إلى M. يمكننا اختيار أي أسماء أو رموز نريدها للنتائج.
بالتحديد، إذا كانت لدينا مجموعة من الإسقاطات مُسماة برموز
من مجموعة غاما مثلاً،
وتستوفي نفس
الشرط كما سابقاً، وهو أن مجموعها يساوي
مصفوفة الهوية، فلدينا قياس إسقاطي
يعمل بنفس الطريقة
تماماً كما سابقاً.
الفرق الوحيد هنا هو أننا نسمح
لنتائج القياس أن تكون عناصر من هذه المجموعة غاما بدلاً من الأعداد الصحيحة من واحد إلى M.
لمثالنا الأول على
القياس الإسقاطي، لنلاحظ أن
قياسات الأساس القياسي هي قياسات إسقاطية.
في هذه الحالة مجموعة
نتائج القياس هي نفس مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية لأي نظام يُقاس.
ومجموعة الإسقاطات
التي تصف القياس هي هذه المجموعة هنا، بافتراض أن سيغما هي
مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية
لنظامنا. هذه كلها إسقاطات
وإذا جمعناها، نحصل على مصفوفة الهوية، فهو قياس إسقاطي صالح
لرؤية كيف يعمل هذا
بمزيد من التفصيل، لنفترض أن
لدينا حالة عشوائية مكتوبة بالشكل
الذي ترونه هنا.
احتمال أن يعطي
القياس النتيجة A، وفقاً للوصف
من قبل لحظات، هو هذه القيمة هنا،
والتي تساوي مربع
القيمة المطلقة للمدخل المقابل
للمتجه ساي، وهو ما نتوقعه.
بشرط أن تكون النتيجة A، تصبح حالة النظام هذه، مرة أخرى، وفقاً
للوصف من قبل لحظات.
إذا بسطنا، لا نحصل
تماماً على الحالة المتوقعة، وهي Ket A.
بدلاً من ذلك نحصل على Ket A
مضروباً في كمية قياسية، وتحديداً، هذه كمية قياسية قيمتها
المطلقة تساوي واحداً،
فهي عدد مركب
على دائرة الوحدة.
هذا يُسمى طور شامل وسنناقش الأطوار الشاملة قريباً، لكن باختصار الآن، هذه
الحالة مكافئة لـ Ket A.
هذا الطور الشامل ليس
له أي أهمية على الإطلاق وسنرى لماذا
عندما نصل إلى مناقشة الأطوار الشاملة.
فبغض النظر عن مسألة الأطوار الشاملة، التي سنتحدث عنها بعد لحظات، نرى أن قياسات الأساس القياسي
هي في الواقع قياسات إسقاطية. لمثال آخر، وهو في الحقيقة امتداد
للمثال السابق،
إذا أجرينا قياس الأساس
القياسي على نظام X ولم نفعل شيئاً لنظام Y، تماماً كما تحدثنا
في الدرس السابق،
فهذا مكافئ تماماً
لقياس النظام X, Y.
بهذا القياس الإسقاطي
هنا.
لدينا هذه الإسقاطات المتوافقة مع الحالات الكلاسيكية لـ X ونضرب تنسورياً مع الهوية على Y
مما يعكس حقيقة أننا
لا نفعل شيئاً لـ Y.
الوصف الخاص بكيفية
عمل القياسات الإسقاطية بشكل عام يخبرنا
بما يحدث في هذا المثال، وسأترك لكم التحقق
من أن هذا في الواقع
مكافئ تماماً لما ناقشناه في الدرس السابق.
هذا كله جميل جداً لأن وصف القياس
الإسقاطي هذا أنظف بطريقة ما ونرى أنه يتناسب مع
هذه الصورة الأعم.
إليكم مثالاً أخيراً على
القياس الإسقاطي.
هذا قياس لـ qubit اثنين.
لهذا القياس
لدينا إسقاطان وبالتالي نتيجتان
ممكنتان هما صفر وواحد.
الإسقاطات معرفة
بدلالة حالات Bell كما ترون هنا.
الإسقاط الأول هو
على الفضاء الممتد بحالات Bell الثلاث المتماثلة والإسقاط الثاني هو
على الفضاء أحادي البعد
الممتد بحالة ساي-، وهي الحالة غير المتماثلة، أو بعبارة أخرى
الحالة التي تُضرب
بعلامة سالب إذا
أجرينا عملية تبديل على الـ qubit الاثنين.
سنرى لاحقاً في السلسلة لماذا هذا قياس مثير للاهتمام.
الآن، إنه مجرد مثال
يرتبط بشيء رأيناه سابقاً،
وهو أساس Bell.
ملاحظة أخيرة عن القياسات الإسقاطية هي أنه كلما كان لديك
قياس إسقاطي، يمكنك دائماً تنفيذ ذلك القياس
باستخدام عمليات أحادية
وقياسات الأساس القياسي.
لهذا المثال بالذات
على القياس، مثلاً، يمكننا بناء circuit كمي ينفذ القياس
كما ترون هنا.
نتخيل أن الـ qubit
الاثنين العلويين هما الـ qubits التي نقيسها بهذا
القياس الإسقاطي وما يمكننا فعله هو
إدخال qubit جديد
مهيأ في البداية
لحالة الصفر. نجري gate Hadamard
تليها gate Fredkin، تليها gate Hadamard أخرى،
وإذا قسنا هذا الـ qubit السفلي بقياس الأساس القياسي، فالتأثير سيكون تماماً كما لو قسنا الـ qubit الاثنين العلويين
بالقياس الإسقاطي
من هذا المثال.
سنحصل على نفس الاحتمالات تماماً للنتيجتين وتأثير القياس على الـ qubit الاثنين العلويين
سيكون هو نفسه أيضاً.
هذا ليس واضحاً أبداً. تحليل مطلوب لرؤية ذلك وهذا التحليل غير معروض هنا.
كما اقترحت سابقاً، سنلقي نظرة أقرب على
هذا القياس بالذات في درس لاحق والآن
إنه مجرد مثال.
النقطة المهمة التي يجب استخلاصها هي أن شيئاً كهذا
ممكن دائماً لأي قياس إسقاطي، فنحن لا نكتسب حقاً
أي قدرات إضافية
بإدخال القياسات الإسقاطية، لكنه مفهوم مفيد جداً وسنتحدث غالباً
عن القياسات الإسقاطية
مع استمرارنا في السلسلة. الجزء الأخير من هذا الدرس يتناول بعض القيود المهمة
للمعلومات الكمية
وما يمكننا فعله بالـ circuits الكمية.
القيد الأول، الذي ربما ليس قيداً بقدر ما هو انحلال، يتعلق بمسألة الأطوار الشاملة
التي ذكرتها قبل قليل. إليكم تعريف ما نعنيه عندما نشير إلى طور شامل.
إذا كان لدينا متجها
حالة كمية، ساي وفاي، بحيث يكون أحدهما
مساوياً للآخر مضروباً في عدد مركب ألفا ما،
فنقول أن الحالتين
تختلفان بطور شامل أو بدلاً من ذلك أنهما متكافئتان حتى طور شامل.
لاحظوا أنه لأن متجهات الحالة الكمية لها نظيم إقليدي يساوي واحداً، الطريقة الوحيدة لتكون هذه
المعادلة صحيحة
هي إذا كانت القيمة المطلقة
لهذا العدد المركب تساوي واحداً، فألفا
يجب أن يقع على دائرة الوحدة.
لنتخيل أن لدينا
حالتين كميتين كهاتين تختلفان بطور شامل ولنفترض أننا نقيس الحالة فاي
بقياس الأساس القياسي.
احتمال الحصول على أي نتيجة A يُعطى بهذا التعبير هنا، وإذا عوضنا
ألفا ضرب ساي بدل فاي،
وهو ما يمكننا فعله لأننا
نفترض أنهما متساويتان، نحصل على هذا الاحتمال.
وإذا بسطنا باستخدام حقيقة أن ألفا يقع على
دائرة الوحدة المركبة، نحصل على هذا الاحتمال.
تذكروا أن هذا هو احتمال أن قياس فاي يعطي النتيجة A، لكن الآن نرى أن
هذا هو نفسه تماماً احتمال أن قياس
ساي يعطي النتيجة A،
فلا يوجد فرق على
الإطلاق في احتمالات النتائج المختلفة للحالتين.
حجة مماثلة تخبرنا بشكل أعم أنه لأي قياس إسقاطي، الاحتمالات متطابقة مرة أخرى.
فبالقياس لا يمكننا
التمييز بين حالتين تختلفان
بطور شامل، حتى بالمعنى الإحصائي.
أخيراً، إذا طبقنا أي عملية
أحادية على الحالة فاي، فمرة أخرى بالتعويض، ما سنحصل عليه هو نفس
العدد المركب ألفا تماماً
مضروباً في ما سنحصل عليه بتطبيق نفس العملية
الأحادية على الحالة ساي.
فالحالتان ستظلان
تختلفان بطور شامل.
خلاصة القول هي أن الحالتين غير قابلتين للتمييز تماماً، فليس هناك حقاً أي
فرق بينهما على الإطلاق
من حيث ما يمكننا
أن نتعلمه عنهما من إجراء عمليات
أحادية وقياسات ولهذا السبب،
نعتبر هاتين
الحالتين متكافئتين أو إذا فضلت، أنهما مجرد تمثيلين متجهيين مختلفين ربما
لنفس الحالة الكمية.
كما قلت في بداية
النقاش، إنه أساساً انحلال
في كيفية وصف الحالات الكمية بمتجهات الحالة الكمية.
على أي حال، ما يعنيه هذا هو أنه يمكننا ببساطة
تجاهل الأطوار الشاملة تماماً كما فعلنا فعلياً عندما وصفنا قياسات
الأساس القياسي
كقياسات إسقاطية. بالمناسبة، هذا الانحلال يحدث فقط في الوصف المبسط
للمعلومات الكمية.
عندما نصف الحالات
الكمية باستخدام مصفوفات الكثافة، كما سنفعل في
الوحدة الثالثة من السلسلة، سيكون لدينا تمثيل
مصفوفي فريد
لكل حالة كمية. مسألة الأطوار الشاملة
ببساطة لا تطرأ في الوصف العام
للمعلومات الكمية.
إنه جانب آخر جاذب
من الوصف العام للمعلومات الكمية،
والذي أستمر في الإشارة إليه، لكن بغض النظر، الأطوار
الشاملة لن تزعجنا
لأننا يمكننا ببساطة ممارسة
حريتنا في تجاهلها.
إليكم مثالاً سريعاً جداً
فقط للتأكد من أن مفهوم الطور الشامل واضح.
إذا كان لدينا حالة سالب، وسالب واحد ضرب حالة سالب، فإن هاتين الحالتين
تختلفان بطور شامل، وبالتحديد لدينا
ألفا يساوي سالب واحد.
من ناحية أخرى، إذا كان لدينا حالة موجب وحالة سالب، فليس لدينا حالتان
تختلفان بطور شامل.
هذان متجهان متعامدان، فهما مستقلان خطياً.
القول بأن متجهي حالة كمية يختلفان بطور شامل
مكافئ للقول بأن المتجهين مرتبطان خطياً،
فبالتأكيد هذان المتجهان
لا يختلفان بطور شامل.
صحيح أن الفرق الوحيد هو أن علامة الموجب هذه
تتحول إلى علامة السالب هذه، لكن هذا ما نسميه فرق
طور نسبي.
هذا مختلف عن الطور الشامل لأننا لا
نضرب المتجه بأكمله في عدد مركب.
وهذا يتوافق مع حقيقة أنه يمكننا التمييز بين
هاتين الحالتين، بالتحديد، إذا
طبقنا عملية Hadamard
ثم قسنا، سنرى صفراً إذا كانت
الحالة حالة موجب وواحداً إذا كانت الحالة حالة سالب.
القيد التالي للمعلومات الكمية الذي سنراه في هذا الدرس
هو نظرية عدم الاستنساخ.
إليكم صياغة واحدة
لنظرية عدم الاستنساخ وهذه الصياغة
بالذات للنظرية محددة وواقعية جداً،
مما سيسهل الحديث عنها. هناك طرق أخرى أكثر عمومية لصياغة نظرية عدم الاستنساخ،
لكننا سنركز على هذه الآن.
نفترض أن لدينا نظامين X و Y لهما نفس مجموعة الحالات الكلاسيكية.
والتي تتكون من
الأعداد الصحيحة من صفر إلى D-1 حيث D لا يقل عن اثنين.
ليس مهماً حقاً ما هي أسماء الحالات الكلاسيكية، لكن باختيار هذه الأسماء سيساعد في تبسيط الأمور.
الأهم هنا
هو أن هناك حالتين كلاسيكيتين على الأقل
مختلفتين، أو بعبارة أخرى، لا نقلق بشأن
الحالة البديهية وغير المثيرة
حيث لدينا حالة كلاسيكية واحدة فقط.
ما تقوله النظرية هو أنه لا توجد عملية أحادية U يمكننا تطبيقها على X, Y بحيث إذا هيأنا
Y لحالة الصفر،
ننسخ أو نستنسخ فعلياً
حالات كمية عشوائية لـ X.
إذا نظرنا إلى هذا
التعبير هنا بمعزل، ما يقوله هو أنه لجميع اختيارات متجه الحالة الكمية ساي لـ X،
تطبيق U على ساي مضروباً
تنسورياً مع حالة الصفر، يعطينا ساي ضرب تنسوري ساي، أو بعبارة أخرى نسختين
مستقلتين من ساي،
وهذا ما سيعنيه لو استطعنا استنساخ الحالات الكمية
وما تقوله النظرية هو أن هذا غير ممكن.
يمكنكم التفكير في هذا
بدلالة الـ circuits وما تقوله النظرية هو
أنكم لن تتمكنوا أبداً من ابتكار gate أو circuit
يعمل كما ترون هنا.
حيث تدخل نسخة واحدة من الحالة ساي مع مجموعة
من qubits المهيأة وتُنتج نسختان من ساي.
يمكنك فعل هذا لاختيارات
معينة من الحالة ساي، لكن لا يمكنك أبداً ابتكار
circuit يعمل بهذه الطريقة لكل حالة كمية ساي،
وهذا ما تقوله النظرية.
من السهل جداً إثبات
هذه النظرية، في الواقع، تتلخص أساساً في حقيقة أن التحويل الذي
نبحث عنه ليس خطياً،
لكن العمليات الأحادية
خطية، فهو ببساطة لا يمكن أن يعمل.
إليكم حجة بمزيد من التفصيل.
افترض أن لدينا عملية أحادية U تستنسخ حالات الأساس القياسي،
Ket 0 و Ket واحد.
نعلم أن الحالات الكلاسيكية
صفر وواحد يجب أن تنتمي لمجموعة حالاتنا الكلاسيكية لأن D لا يقل عن اثنين.
لكن هذا يعني بالخطية
أنه إذا كان X في حالة موجب، والتي يمكننا كتابتها هكذا،
فإن النتيجة هي هذه التركيبة الخطية من هاتين الحالتين هنا.
لكن هذا ليس السلوك الصحيح. الشرط على U هو أن
U تستنسخ حالة الموجب،
مما يعني أنه يجب أن تتحقق
هذه المعادلة هنا.
هاتان الحالتان ليستا
متماثلتين وبالتالي لا يعمل الأمر وهذا كل ما في الأمر.
فقط بعض الملاحظات الإضافية
حول نظرية عدم الاستنساخ.
أولاً، هذه الصياغة لنظرية
عدم الاستنساخ مطلقة بمعنى ما.
تقول ببساطة أن عملية أحادية U تعمل بالضبط
هكذا غير موجودة.
فقد تتساءل هل توجد
عملية أحادية U تفعل
هذا تقريبياً بالنسبة لطريقة ما لوصف
تقريب للعبارة. هناك مفاهيم مختلفة
للتقريب قد يهتم بها المرء
وسنرى اثنين منها
في الوحدة الثالثة من السلسلة، لكن لهذه المفاهيم
المختلفة للتقريب،
هناك صياغات كمية
لنظرية عدم الاستنساخ تضع حدوداً قوية على مدى جودة الاستنساخ التقريبي.
ملاحظة ثانية هي أن نسخ أو استنساخ حالات الأساس القياسي
ممكن بالتأكيد.
مثلاً، gate NOT المتحكم بها تنسخ حالات الأساس القياسي لـ qubit.
هذا لا يتناقض
مع نظرية عدم الاستنساخ. النقطة هي أن الاستنساخ بمعنى نظرية عدم الاستنساخ يتطلب
أن يعمل هذا ليس فقط
لحالات الأساس القياسي
بل لجميع الحالات.
gate NOT المتحكم بها
بالتأكيد لا تستنسخ حالة الموجب مثلاً.
وأخيراً، من الجدير بالإشارة إلى أن هناك أيضاً نظرية عدم استنساخ للحالات
الاحتمالية.
إنها فقط ليست شيئاً
يتحدث عنه الناس أو يهتمون به.
إذا اختار شخص ما
بتاً بشكل عشوائي، مثلاً، بطريقة عشوائية ما
لتعيين الاحتمالات للقيمتين ثم
أعطاك ذلك البت،
بالطبع لا توجد طريقة لك للحصول على عينتين مستقلتين
من ذلك البت العشوائي.
أنت ببساطة لا تعرف ما هي
الاحتمالات.
يمكنك نسخ البت تماماً كما تنسخ NOT المتحكم بها
حالات الأساس القياسي، لكن هذا ليس نفس الشيء مثل استنساخ الحالة الاحتمالية.
أنت ببساطة لا تملك
معلومات كافية لفعل ذلك. أي بت عشوائي أُعطي لك لا يخبرك ما
كانت الاحتمالات.
إنه مجرد بت.
استحالة استنساخ
الحالة الاحتمالية تتبع من نفس المنطق تماماً كما في الإطار الكمي.
الاستنساخ عملية غير خطية، بينما العمليات الاحتمالية، تماماً كالعمليات الأحادية، خطية.
على أي حال، ليس مفاجئاً
أننا لا نستطيع استنساخ حالة احتمالية و
بطريقة ما ليس مثيراً للاهتمام بقدر حقيقة أننا لا نستطيع
استنساخ حالة كمية،
لكن النقطة هي ببساطة ملاحظة أن هذه ليست ظاهرة كمية
بشكل فريد.
القيد الأخير
للمعلومات الكمية الذي سنناقشه في هذا الدرس هو أنه لا يمكن
التمييز بشكل مثالي
بين حالتين كميتين غير متعامدتين.
طريقة أخرى لقول هذا
هي أنه إذا كان يمكن التمييز بشكل مثالي بين حالتين كميتين، فيجب أن تكونا متعامدتين.
ما نعنيه عندما نشير
إلى التمييز المثالي بين حالتين كميتين، ساي وفاي، هو أن هناك طريقة
للتفريق بينهما
بدون أي فرصة للخطأ.
بدلالة نموذج الـ circuit الكمي، يمكننا التعبير عن هذا كما
ترون هنا على الشاشة.
لدينا عملية أحادية U ما، والتي يمكن تنفيذها
كـ circuit كمي أو يمكننا التفكير في U بشكل مجرد
كعملية أحادية
وكمدخل تأخذ U إما الحالة ساي أو الحالة فاي
مع مجموعة من qubits المهيأة، والتي يمكنكم اعتبارها qubits مساحة عمل تساعد بطريقة ما في
عملية التمييز هذه.
بعد تطبيق U، يُقاس الـ qubit العلوي بقياس الأساس القياسي وهنا يأتي جزء
التمييز المثالي.
إذا كانت الحالة المدخلة ساي، فيجب أن يعطي القياس
النتيجة صفر، 100% من الوقت، وإذا كانت
الحالة المدخلة فاي،
فيجب أن يعطي القياس
النتيجة واحد، مرة أخرى بنسبة 100%.
ليس مهماً ما هي
حالات هذه الـ qubits الأخرى بعد تطبيق U.
كل ما يهم هو هذا البت الذي نحصل عليه من القياس لأن هذا هو البت الذي يخبرنا بأي الحالتين بدأنا.
لبعض اختيارات الحالتين، ساي وفاي، سيكون ممكناً إجراء تمييز مثالي كهذا
وللأخرى لن يكون.
وما سنلاحظه هو أنه
إذا كان ممكناً فعل هذا، فإن ساي وفاي يجب أن
تكونا حالتين متعامدتين
وهذا يعني أنه إذا لم تكن فاي
وساي متعامدتين، فلا يمكنك التمييز بينهما بشكل مثالي.
فلنرى لماذا التمييز المثالي يستلزم التعامد.
سنبدأ بكتابة معادلتين تعبران عما يعبر عنه
هذان الرسمان.
إذا فكرنا في الحالة الكمية التي نحصل عليها بعد تطبيق U على
مجموعة من qubits المهيأة مع الحالة ساي،
نرى أنه يجب أن تأخذ
هذا الشكل هنا، حيث باي صفر هو متجه حالة كمية ما يمثل حالة
كل هذه الـ qubits
عدا العلوي. ليس لدينا أي معلومات
عن هذه الحالة الكمية، باي صفر، يمكن أن تكون أي شيء،
لكننا نعلم أن الحالة
بأكملها يجب أن تبدو هكذا لأن هذه هي الطريقة
الوحيدة لضمان أن القياس يعطي
النتيجة صفر، 100% من الوقت.
ولدينا معادلة مماثلة
للثانية.
هذه المرة الـ qubit العلوي
يجب أن يكون في حالة الواحد ومثل باي صفر، الحالة
باي واحد يمكن أن تكون أي شيء.
وبالإضافة إلى عدم وجود
معلومات عن باي واحد، لا نعرف أيضاً شيئاً
عن العلاقة بين باي صفر وباي واحد.
على حد علمنا، هاتان مجرد
حالتان كميتان عشوائيتان.
ما يمكننا فعله بعد ذلك هو
ضرب طرفي هاتين المعادلتين
من كلا الجهتين في U المرافقة المنقولة، أي المرافق المنقول لـ U.
وإذا فعلنا ذلك، نحصل على المعادلتين
اللتين ترونهما هنا.
نستخدم حقيقة أن U المرافقة المنقولة ضرب U تساوي مصفوفة الهوية.
فلهذا لا نرى U أو U المرافقة المنقولة في الطرف الأيسر من أي من المعادلتين.
والآن يمكننا اعتبار الجداء الداخلي بين ساي وفاي.
إنه نفس الجداء الداخلي
لساي وفاي مضروباً في الجداء
الداخلي لحالة L صفر مع نفسها
لأن الجداء الداخلي
لأي حالة مع نفسها يساوي واحداً وهذا يشمل حالة L صفر.
والآن إذا نظرنا لمعادلتينا، نرى أن هذا التعبير هنا يساوي الجداء الداخلي للمتجهات
الممثلة بالمعادلتين. وبالتحديد إنه الجداء الداخلي بين الطرفين
الأيسرين من هاتين المعادلتين.
فيمكننا بنفس القدر
التعبير عن هذا الجداء الداخلي كالجداء الداخلي للمتجهات الممثلة بالطرفين
الأيمنين من هاتين المعادلتين،
لأن الطرف الأيسر يساوي
الطرف الأيمن لكلتا المعادلتين.
فنحصل على هذا التعبير هنا، وهو الجداء الداخلي
للطرفين الأيمنين من المعادلتين أو بالتكافؤ،
إنه المرافق المنقول للأول مضروباً في الثاني.
U ضرب U المرافقة المنقولة تساوي
مصفوفة الهوية، لأن U أحادية فتختفي.
ويمكننا التبسيط قليلاً للحصول على جداء
هذين الجداءين الداخليين.
الآن تذكروا أننا لا نعرف شيئاً عن العلاقة
بين باي صفر وباي واحد، فلا نعرف ما هو
جداؤهما الداخلي.
هذا لغز بالنسبة لنا. لكن مهما كان، نحن نضربه في الجداء الداخلي لـ Ket 0 و Ket واحد، والذي يساوي صفراً.
فالنتيجة النهائية هي أننا
نحصل على القيمة صفر، لكن هذا ما أردنا إثباته، الجداء الداخلي بين
ساي وفاي يساوي صفراً.
إذاً الحالتان متعامدتان.
فلا تحاولوا التمييز
بشكل مثالي بين حالتين كميتين غير
متعامدتين، ببساطة لا يمكنكم ذلك.
هناك عكس للعبارة
التي أثبتناها للتو، وهو أن الحالات الكمية المتعامدة يمكن دائماً التمييز بينها بشكل مثالي،
وهذا ليس صعباً رؤيته
إذا استخدمنا حقيقة ذكرتها سابقاً في الدرس.
تحديداً إذا كانت ساي
وفاي حالتين متعامدتين، فأحد الأشياء التي يمكننا فعلها هو اختيار أي مصفوفة أحادية U
عمودها الأول والثاني
هما الحالتان.
نعلم أنه من الممكن
دائماً فعل هذا ولا يهم
لأغراض هذه المهمة بالضبط كيف تُختار هذه المصفوفة الأحادية.
كل ما يهم هو أن هذين هما العمودان الأولان.
لا نحتاج أي qubits إضافية. إذا طبقنا ببساطة U على
الحالتين الممكنتين، فسنحصل على هاتين
النتيجتين الممكنتين.
وإذا قسنا الـ qubit الأعلى، وتذكروا أنه الـ qubit الأيمن، فسنحصل على صفر أو واحد
حسب الحالة التي بدأنا بها.
بدلاً من ذلك، يمكننا اعتبار
قياس إسقاطي بنتيجتين صفر وواحد
معرف كما ترون هنا.
في هذه الحالة، القياس
يعتمد فقط على ساي.
هذا القياس يميز بشكل مثالي
ساي من أي حالة متعامدة مع ساي.
إذا قسنا ساي بهذا القياس الإسقاطي، فسنحصل على النتيجة
صفر باحتمال واحد كما تبين هذه المعادلات.
ولأي حالة فاي
متعامدة مع ساي، سنحصل على النتيجة
واحد باحتمال واحد.
لن أمر بتفاصيل
هذه الحسابات، لكن إذا كنتم مهتمين، أشجعكم على المرور
بالتفاصيل بأنفسكم.
وهذه نهاية الدرس الثالث. غطينا الكثير من
المواد في هذا الدرس، بما في ذلك الـ circuits الكمية،
والجداء الداخلي والتعامد، والإسقاطات والقياسات الإسقاطية، وحقيقة أن الأطوار الشاملة لا تهم،
ونظرية عدم الاستنساخ، وحقيقة أن الحالات غير المتعامدة لا يمكن التمييز بينها بشكل مثالي بينما الحالات المتعامدة يمكن ذلك.
آمل أن تنضموا إلي
للدرس الرابع قريباً، وهو الدرس الأخير في
الوحدة الأولى من السلسلة.
في الدرس الرابع، سنتحدث عن ثلاثة
أمثلة مهمة جداً، النقل الآني، والتشفير فائق الكثافة،
ومتراجحة CHSH أو لعبة CHSH كما تُوصف أحياناً.
وداعاً حتى ذلك الحين،